une conférence de presse commune entre
les maires du creusot et de torcy
un événement rare qui s'explique par la
gravité de la situation dans ces deux
villes
gangréné depuis plusieurs mois par un
trafic de drogue grandissant la première
réponse à apporter sur le e c'est la
solidarité et la cohésion républicaine
même si nous sommes deux villes
différentes
nous avons des politiques des politiques
sociales des politiques éducatives en
commun et bien sûr toute la prévention
de la délinquance une adolescente touché
par une balle à la jambe il y a dix
jours au creusot
un jeune tué ce week-end dans un
règlement de comptes entre trafiquants à
torcy la situation est grave
le maire du creusot demandent depuis des
mois plus de moyens pour lutter et le
retour d'une police de proximité pas une
présence ponctuelle une présence qui
soit la plus répétée possible même si
elle n'est pas en permanence
cette police de proximité qui a disparu
et qui n'est jamais revenu par exemple
nous en avons besoin et c'est ce que
nous demandons parce que c'est ça qui
permet de garder le lien entre le
citoyen et les policiers donc ceux qui
doivent assurer le l'ordre lé maire de
torcy et du creusot lance ce matin un
appel à tous les élus du département
pour une marche solidaire 70 et qui
partira du quartier du tennis au creusot
pour rejoindre torcy ici où les
événements dramatiques de ce week-end se
sont déroulés une marche solidaire pour
demander plus de moyens pour lutter
contre ce trafic de drogue et assurer la
sécurité des habitants